my fellow Americans tonight I want to
speak with you about our nation's
unprecedented response to the corona
virus outbreak that started in China and
is now spreading throughout the world we
declared a public health emergency and
issued the highest level of travel
warning on other countries as the virus
spread it's horrible infection and
taking early intense action we have seen
dramatically fewer cases of the virus in
the United States than are now present
in Europe the European Union failed to
take the same precautions and restrict
travel from China and other hotspots as
a result a large number of new clusters
in the United States were seeded by
travelers from Europe after consulting
with our top government health
professionals I have decided to take
several strong but necessary actions to
protect the health and well-being of all
Americans to keep new cases from
entering our shores we will be
suspending all travel from Europe to the
United States for the next 30 days the
new rules will go into effect Friday at
midnight these restrictions will be
adjusted subject to conditions on the
ground there will be exemptions for
Americans who have undergone appropriate
screenings and these prohibitions will
not only apply to the tremendous amount
of Trade and cargo but various other
things as we get approval anything
coming from Europe to the United States
is what we are discussing these
restrictions will also not apply to the
United Kingdom today the World Health
Organization officially announced that
this is a global pandemic we have been
in frequent contact with our allies and
we are marshalling the full power of the
federal government and the private
sector to protect the American people
this is the most aggressive and
comprehensive effort to confront a
foreign virus in modern history this is
not a financial crisis this is just
a temporary moment of time that we will
overcome together as a nation and as a
world I will never hesitate to take any
necessary steps to protect the lives
health and safety of the American people
I will always put the well-being of
America first if we are vigilant and we
can reduce the chance of infection which
we will we will significantly impede the
transmission of the virus the rut the
virus will not have a chance against us
no nation is more prepared or more
resilient than the United States
you